all right so you probably noticed this
at your local pharmacy recently cold and
flu medicine is a lot harder to find
empty shelves in some cases it's a
problem that retailers say they're
dealing with because of the pandemic
hector mahia reporting live this morning
from a local drug store near los angeles
boulevard and convention center hector
what else are you hearing from them
well we're hearing that that demand for
over-the-counter medicine is shooting
through the roof retailers say it's
happening all across the country not
just here in the valley and check out
that walgreens here right across the
street that is one of the retailers
affected when i reached out to them
yesterday they told me they are working
with suppliers to make sure they have
enough supply to meet the demand so that
increased demand is for cough cold and
flu medicine
pair that with the pandemic related
hiccups affecting the entire supply
chain and in cases we have these empty
shelves at some stores
coveted symptoms are also similar so
we're told people are stocking up buying
in large quantities
so there's no reason to panic though if
you run if you come into if you find
some unstocked shelves the retail
association of nevada recommends going
online or just try another store and
you'll likely find exactly what you're
looking for you can also look up if a
store has something in stock online
ahead of time before you head out there
so walgreens also told us the items that
may be unavailable are only temporary or
isolated shortages so again you are able
to find the product you're looking for
you just have to try a little harder
reporting live hector mejia live local
now